[Música]
hace un poco más de 10 años mientras
estaba sentado aguardando que me
atendiera la doctora en la sala de
espera me puso a conversar con otros
pacientes sobre la evolución de nuestros
tratamientos yo hacía días que venía
como angustiado como como enojado con la
vida de hecho justo antes de llegar al
consultorio me había peleado con todo el
mundo
el tráfico era un caos y volvió el
justiciero de las calles como le
llamaban mis amigos cargándome cuando
cuando era más chico que manejaba
queriendo enseñar a manejar a todo el
mundo ese personaje había vuelto con
todo
en este contexto ella estaba hace más de
una hora hablando con este chico
éramos íntimos
claramente él estaba en el mismo proceso
que yo en el mismo tratamiento pero lo
he empezado hace un tiempito antes
me propuse sincerarse con él y contarle
la bronca que sentía
pensaba porque a mí
si no lo dice mal a nadie
porque no puedo ser sano
en ese momento el otro paciente me miró
me sonrío y me dijo y por qué no a vos
quién [ __ ] te crees que sos que no te
puede pasar a vos aquí [ __ ] le ganaste
en ese momento me llamo la doctora y
entré con una mezcla entre susto y enojo
entre hasta le hice el comentario de lo
que había pasado no no no podía entender
la violencia de lo que me dijo
cuando salí el paciente no estaba y la
verdad es que nunca más lo volví a ver
me lo imaginé puede ser siempre me lo
pregunto
lo que sí sé es que esa persona me
generó un cambio de 180 grados quién iba
a pensar que en una sala de espera en la
que pasaba tantas tardes por semana con
un simple comentario me iba a generar un
cambio de actitud
les voy a explicar mejor a los 18 meses
de vida contraje una enfermedad que se
llama síndrome hemolítico urémico esa
enfermedad deterioro la función de mis
dos riñones a tal punto que a mis padres
le dijeron que tarde o temprano iba a
necesitar un trasplante de riñón
esa situación se dio cuando yo tenía 24
años y una muchacha fue compatible y me
donó su riñón
nosotras plantamos en la fundación
favaloro en 2006
lo cierto es que un trasplante no es la
solución final es un tratamiento que
siempre continúa
y requiere de extremos cuidados de
chequeos constantes de un cóctel
bastante fuerte de medicamentos
y muchas veces a pesar de que se toma
todas estas medidas el rechazo es
inevitable
en mi caso una razón médica del rechazo
mi sistema inmune que es como nuestro
antivirus constantes reconoció al riñón
citó de mama y lo comenzó a atacar como
un órgano extraño extranjero y otra
razón no está médica la realidad es que
mi viejita se murió de repente de un
momento para otro y yo afloje la fluye
de la cabeza me caí del 8 y es como
cuando uno se levanta en la mesa y
arrastra mente él se lleva todo por
delante
desde ese momento estoy en lista de
espera para un segundo trasplante de
riñón en el incucai y a la vez para
reemplazar la función renal que ya no
tengo voy a un tratamiento de un
tratamiento que se llama hemodiálisis
que es la hemodiálisis básicamente es un
tratamiento por el cual me conectan dos
mangueritas en el brazo la sangre sales
por una de las mangueras se limpia se
filtra en la máquina y vuelve el brazo
por la otra manguerita es decir lo que a
ustedes le hacen sus riñones las 24
horas del día a mí me lo hace una
máquina tres veces por semana cuatro o
cinco horas dependiendo de la sesión del
caso
con toda esta noticia imagínense volvió
de vuelta a la angustia volvió en el ojo
tomaba la diálisis como un tratamiento
acaparador de mi tiempo y hasta de mi
vida
y me acordé del paciente en la sala de
espera
él me hubiera dicho y hasta quizás con
nuestras palabras
no te das cuenta que si esa máquina no
existiera vos hoy estaría muerto
no te das cuenta que tienes una segunda
oportunidad
yo hoy sigo estando en lista de espera
de trasplante
sigo siendo tres veces por semana
diálisis pero soy otro
me apropien de una frase de bob marley
que dice nunca sabes lo fuerte que eres
hasta que ser fuerte es tu única opción
y mi la propia es mía la aplico todos
los días
con esa misma actitud tomé esta batalla
como un partido jugué muchos años al
rugby y me pasó que tuve que enfrentar
muchas veces a chicos más grandes y más
fuertes que yo
y en esas situaciones en la cancha en
las que el grandote agarra la pelota y
encima encara para donde estas dos
tenemos dos opciones o nos preparamos
para el golpe entrenamos nuestra técnica
de tackle y usamos nuestras habilidades
para robarle la pelota o dos salimos
corriendo no queda otra
yo soy un superhéroe no no soy un
superhéroe pero
pude parar la pelota y pensar
creo que puedo hacer algo con lo que me
toco
no les pasa que muchas veces nos
quedamos frisados quejándonos de porque
subió el precio del dólar o cuánto subió
el tomate perita la lechuga o
quejándonos de de situaciones que
realmente no podemos controlar
lo único que está a nuestro alcance es
la reacción que tenemos ante esas
situaciones
les quiero graficar como trato
reaccionario cuando sos chiquito una de
las primeras cosas que te dicen los
entrenadores de rugby es cuando atacamos
pelota en dos manos
corre derecho corre para delante y
bandera bandera bandera te dicen sólo
trató de aplicar eso es lo que trato de
aplicar
siento que ese paciente en la sala de
espera me hizo reflexionar acerca de mi
actitud ante la vida
hoy se acepto que me haya tocado esto a
mí ya no estoy enojado con la gente o
con el mundo o con algún ente
sobrenatural que me quiere atacar a
algún que otro enojo me puede agarrar
pero es interesante pensar como con un
simple comentario en una sala de espera
un comentario que no duró más de 5
segundos de alguien que generó un cambio
en su vida genera un cambio en la mía
como si fuera una hora expansiva
y hoy estoy acá para intentar continuar
esa ola expansiva porque soy de los que
piensan que si no puedes cambiar las
circunstancias tenés que cambiar la
perspectiva y los cambios de perspectiva
contagian
si yo me hubiera quedado con esa actitud
enojada y angustiada que tenía en la
sala de espera no solo hoy no estaría
acá sino que no podría producir un
cambio en mí ni en nadie
son todos los días a un micro tina voy a
diálisis voy al club voy a trabajar
y sé que mis compañeros en cada uno de
esos lugares cuando me ven tienen
alguien en quien confiar en que por lo
menos no va a bajar los brazos en que
está comprometido contagiados ellos
también empujan como un equipo de rugby
cuando ves que hay uno que se está
rompiendo el lomo por por los otros 14 y
no puedes ser menos
pienso en matilda por ejemplo matilde
asignación a bajita chiquita setenta y
pico años en mi compañía de diálisis
enojada enojada con todo el mundo
a matilda la pude comenzar que la
máquina de diálisis no es esa máquina de
[ __ ]
en la máquina que nos da vida
y las enfermeras no son solo las
enfermeras son las personas que nos
salvan la vida cada dos días
siento que estas pequeñas circunstancias
pueden
hace generar un cambio en nuestro
círculo pero también a nivel sociedad es
ahora se puede convertir en marea
pensemos en el caso de justina locales
muchos lo habrán escuchado o se habrán
de jústiz justicia una nena que estaba
lista de espera de trasplante de corazón
en este caso también en la fundación
favaloro en emergencia nacional a pesar
de la difícil batalla que tenía ella por
delante
se eligió se propuso eligió pensar en
los que estábamos en la misma situación
que ella ayudemos a todos los que
podamos le dijo a los padres sus padres
comenzaron el saola que ya había logrado
el récord de registrados como donantes
voluntarios en el lugar y fueron por más
esa marea consiguió modificar la ley de
trasplante y hoy la nueva ley justina
gracias a la cual todos los mayores de
18 somos donantes está en vigencia
entonces justo y logró no desanimarse
ante la situación que estaba viviendo él
logró no aferrarse al problema que tenía
y
pudo correrse de ese lugar y contagiar a
su círculo y ese entorno
[Música]
para el momento que estoy preparando
esta charla somos 10 mil 582 personas en
lista de espera de trasplantes y algún
órgano en nuestro país
para que se den una idea es tres veces
el tamaño del teatro gran rex
agosto de 2018 el primer mes después de
la sanción de la ley justina fue el
récord histórico de trasplantes en
nuestro país
214 trasplantes de 88 donantes
quiero decir si nos dejamos llevar por
el enojo nos perdemos la parte más
importante de la película
nos ponemos trabas a nosotros mismos y
generamos tensiones entre nosotros
sin entender que el otro no es nuestro
enemigo sino que podríamos trabajar en
conjunto
les voy a dar otro ejemplo
si logramos des enojarnos sí si me
permiten la palabra vamos a lograr
pensar que quizás sí quizás podemos
mejorar la calidad de vida de todos
incluso de quienes estamos en esta
espera un trasplante
con la ira encima vamos a pensar por
ejemplo que la ambulancia no va a ser
todo para salvarnos para sacarlos los
órganos
ustedes se creen que si fuese tan fácil
conseguir un órgano compatible yo
estaría siete años en lista de espera
siete años
me gusta esperar
a alguien le gusta esperar
imagínense hace siete años que estoy
esperando
sí señora hace siete años que no soy un
gran compañero de ruta jamás voy a pedir
pasar para ir al baño jamás
[Aplausos]
cuando cuando reservo cuando me voy de
viaje primero reservo el centro de
diálisis
después reservo el hotel hola y por la
cual viajar no me queda otra
a lo que voy haciendo ese ejercicio tan
simple y tan difícil a la vez si nos
podemos correr desde este enojo
podemos mirar la situación de otra forma
ser donante positivamente implica
ponerse en el lugar del otro que no tuvo
la misma suerte que nosotros
pero de vuelta a la pelota y pienso
pienso en el paciente en la sala de
espera
y estoy convencido que lo neurálgico es
el cambio de actitud los invito a todos
a generar ese cambio de actitud a hacer
la primera gotita en su propia bola y
generar esa marea y les aseguro que
cuando nos juntemos vamos a empujar
todos para mismo lado
y si me nos encontrará quejándose de lo
que la vida del expuso adelante yo le
preguntaría quién [ __ ] se creen que
son aquí en [ __ ] le ganaron
[Aplausos]